my name is Brook Watson I work at a
company called eco Health Alliance you
may have heard of it before I work with
gnome I do in fact have a snake who as
much cuter than his it's not a rivalry
it's fine her name is Judith she's right
there she's very wonderful but I'm not
gonna spend too much and I also should
say that I am often the beneficiary of
gnomes excellent data packages so
they've been super useful in my analysis
process but I'm not gonna spend too much
time talking about eco health because
today I'm talking about a sort of side
project that is an hour package that I
created that is has just one function
it's pretty playful you know fun package
that I hope you guys find useful but
also kind of bring some delight into
your workflows but I also think that it
serves as a powerful metaphor for the
ways that we think about learning both
individually and in community and the
ways that one can move from an R user to
an art developer if that is something
that you want to do so the package is
called Bert
but I realized yesterday that I had
never said this name out loud because
obviously I'm creating the package
online and that with my accent it
doesn't really come out right it's
supposed to be pronounced like this
though I would also accept this the
first sound is by a very wonderful
gentleman called gucci mane and the
second is Birdman and this package is
available on github so you can download
it front using dev tools and it has
exactly one function again a function
that I find hard to pronounce and it
plays a short sound when it is called so
if you are wondering how to pronounce
the function name and the my walk-on
song was it familiar to you this might
be helpful so that's the function and
basically it's an alarm it's like a
kitchen timer for your code so the use
case for birds that I often find myself
running sort of two to ten minute jobs
these aren't the long scripts that
you're leaving running overnight and
then going home and praying that they're
working in the morning these are the
really quick ones that are long enough
for you to be able to move away from
your code for some period of time but
that are short enough that you don't
want to dive into emails for the rest of
the afternoon so you might want to be
reminded that something is going on over
in the background and if you want to do
that audibly you can use BRR
so this is an example of maybe you want
to update all of your packages that
takes kind of a while you don't know how
long it will take you can use scrap and
and flavor pipe can tell you when your
script is done or a little John can or
Birdman can so sometimes you want to use
this to celebrate that you are done
running a simulation but sometimes you
might want to use it to alert yourself
to the fact that something has gone
wrong so I often use them in functions
usually only functions that I'm sharing
with myself unless you warn your
co-workers or you're pranking your
co-workers to kind of use faces so this
function when it's called on a new on
one will just run no problems but if
it's called on the character dj khaled
will tell you that something is amiss
you can also use this to help increase
the level of testing that you do so I
have only recently started improving by
practices around using things like the
assert that package to do unit test to
make sure that everything is running in
the ways that it should and this sort of
goes hand-in-hand with what Emily
Robinson was saying earlier about
creating reproducible examples sometimes
breaking things down to the smallest
size and reminding yourself that the
world is working the way that it should
be at least on that small scale is
really valuable so you might want to
include four in two different two
different sounds one might be positive
so without burn in this function in this
script you could just you would get a
true when you need to and you would get
a false when things aren't equal so with
it you get and if you if something's
going wrong and you need to hold up oh
dear
you can be told to hold up so there are
51 songs right now in the Pat or clips
they're not quite songs right now in the
package they are
they can be called numerically or they
can be called by their name which are
there's some sort of naming convention
based on various artists names and if
some artist is not included you'll get a
random sound so I recognize that if you
are a person who cares about these
things I may have neglected your
favorite artist and I recognize that
this is a very limited list even though
it's 51 people I only have one of the
three amigos it's not even the best me
go let's take off so I might have left
something out and if that's the case
then you can fork to this and github and
submit a pull request or make your own
package and so that sort of brings me to
the making of this package that's the
it's a one function in the entire
package but there's kind of a back story
behind it that I think says something
more about the ways that we contribute
in this open-source community so the
mother of ber is a package called beeper
that is very perfect and delightful in
its own right that many of you may use
heard some audible cheers it's very
wonderful beeper was created by this guy
Rasmus Baath and it plays small sounds
most many video game sounds so if you
want to celebrate the end of a code you
might run
right so already perfect it doesn't
can't be improved upon can it so I
immediately shared this with my
co-workers and immediately drove into a
conversation about how we could add
different sounds and beeper does include
functionality to include a URL as the
function argument to a wave path if you
have like a wave file that's on the
internet you can play that and it will
play that sound it can play a whole song
if you like there's also like Spotify
like you can have other song players but
you can play songs in our so we also a
co-worker and I really like a website
called the rat board that has all these
lives that I pulled from this is again a
photo photo of Gucci Mane who had a very
inspirational glow-up season last year
and who inspired much of this package
and so if these files had existed in
wave form on the report com
this probably would have been the end of
the story we would have played them and
had a little bit of fun and it would
have been great but because they did it
and because I sort of had a hook in my
brain that was like really focused on
fixing this problem that sent me down a
rabbit hole of trying to get these audio
files in wave form so I started out
trying to scrape them from the website
using a hitter and our vest packages
which are really helpful for scraping
HTML web pages but this website isn't in
HTML it's in JavaScript primarily so I
had to convert that from Java I don't
know any JavaScript and all the HTML and
CSS I know is things that I learned when
I was in the seventh grade because I
wanted my myspace to look cool so so but
these are all things that I was able to
scrap together as I was making this
because I was really engaged in the
process and by the time I had all of
that data which involves a lot of sort
of cleaning names with stringer and
other tidy verse packages I had done a
lot of work and wanted to wrap it up
into a package with dev tools and the
final step in the process was sharing it
with the community so it's on github I
tweeted about it I talked about it in
with our ladies community and which
again is something that Emily discussed
earlier and that many of you are members
of and many of you are familiar with and
this is my like my personal community
there are a lot of other like really
supportive our communities in New York
as many people have mentioned is a
really sort of welcoming environment and
so I think I think there's an old sort
of patriarchal sentence that we all know
like phrase that we all know and love
that behind every man behind every
successful man is a woman right we've
all heard that for that sentence but I
think a more appropriate sentence is
that behind every successful woman is
like ten other people hyping her up in
the Our Lady slack because that's really
been my experience and so all this has
really led me to develop these thoughts
about how one can become an open-source
contributor and a developer of our
packages and this is just one way this
is obviously a kind of a toy example but
I think it's really useful in thinking
about the ways that we can take things
apart and learn from them and put them
back together if it's something that
we're interested in I don't really
particularly care about JavaScript but I
learned a lot about it because I wanted
to use it to make something that I
thought would be fun and that I thought
like I could share with my friends so
just a reminder well I think you we
often start by copying something that
exists right you copy the code of
somebody who you admire you take a
script that you don't understand and you
start pulling it apart we do this from
childhood we look this is how we learn
how to draw how we learn how to do math
we start by copying and once we copy
enough times we can learn how to start
adding things that we like and often we
mess it up and in the process that
creates something new and often we
intentionally just continue to add more
layers until something has we have
created a new
and this is like the nature the
fundamental nature of remixes right it's
taking something that is rooted in a
tradition and adding the new generation
that is now learning about and adding
their contributions to that tradition
so copying is like not a great doesn't
have a great reputation especially in
sort of academic worlds we don't think
that this is something we should be
bragging about that we often want to say
that what we made is our own but we know
that that's not the case and everyone is
influenced by other people and I think
there are important distinctions between
good copying and bad copying or good
good theft and bad theft so good copying
takes from many different people and
pulls from many different resources and
it honors and acknowledges and credits
the creators of those resources and it
is a platform for deep study so good
copying is sort of the taking a lawn
mower apart to understand how it works
and then put it back together it's
useful to a person in understanding the
way that systems are made and then in in
the end it finally transforms and
remixes something into a new version so
as always Kanye has some deep thoughts
on this as well that he shared recently
and I think we think of Kanye West as
someone who's really original and who
has made a lot of new popularized a lot
of new kinds of music and has done a lot
of really sort of avant-garde things in
its art and in that he is constantly
talking about his influences and he's
constantly reaching from different areas
and pulling fashion and music and all
kinds of different things together in
making something new and so I think when
we think about originality what we're
not thinking about starting making
something new from scratch we're
thinking about pulling different areas
together to combine
whether that's combining different
styles of music or using our tools to
make a music thing any way that you want
it to sort of like remix something
that's what it's about making those
diagonal connections and so as always
I'm shocked that I'm the first person to
have an xkcd slide today but as always
xkcd says it better than I can
when you take something from somebody
who influences you in the open source
community you're not taking it from them
you're when you're copying something you
make to of that thing and so I think
this is a really helpful framework when
we're thinking about building from
others and learning from others and
contributing to to this community so I
really enjoy this I don't consider
myself as a developer first I consider
myself sort of more of a an analyst and
a scientist but this is a really fun way
for me to get involved as someone who
doesn't have a computer science
background doesn't doesn't meet all of
the tech check boxes I think if anything
what I want folks to take away from this
talk is that the barrier to entry is
much lower than it might seem so that's
about all I've got that if you want to
sort of go back to these slides they're
on my github I also have written up a
blog post that goes into more detail
about sort of a code line by line how I
got these audio files how I made them
into a package it's been a really fun
process for me and I think like if
anybody is interested in trying to get
started in this and doesn't feel as
though they're a developer this is
something that they want to contend
before I'm more than happy to talk to
folks I think it's something I would
really want to encourage also Judy does
have an Instagram she is open to
sponsored content
brand partnerships you guys can reach
out she's got a fresh nineteen followers
maybe so that's my job
[Applause]
you